Do you have any supplement sales or discodes coming up and do you share those ahead of time?
Well, I share them with you as soon as we get them. I don't we don't have any right now
If order a more than one bottle with the subscribe and save off checked will the same number of bottles be shipped or does it to fall back to one item?
But when you subscribe to something you're subscribing to individual products, we have people that subscribe to 20 different things. We have people that make multiple descriptions because they have one subscription that they get every three weeks and another subscription they get every six weeks with three other different things so you have to kind of play that out.
As the 5% subscription discount apply to sale or discounted products as well.
And typically it depends if we do have fire sales all the time and that has to do with products that are put on fire sale because they're at expiration date.
I understand the product and expiration date and the products are put there because the FDA requires it.
But the truth is, there's a lot of products that literally never expire.
A literal multiband is there something like that?
That will never ever expire.
Products that are antioxidants are never going to expire. I'll give you an example. One company that we use tested a product that they had in their warehouse that that one of the CEOs was holding because it was one of the first products they ever made back in like 1970 or 1965 or something.
So they thought, well, this would be fun. Let's let's have a few of these to the lab to see how they test it tested at 90% of its listed capacity after like 50 years.
And the reason is it's because it had antioxidants in it. So if anything that has antioxidants in it, it's literally got a forever shelf life. So don't throw out those supplements that have antioxidants in it.
So, but we can't really sell them once they reach expiration. So we put about discounted heavily discounted and those you cannot do a subscription of those because we those are a limited number. We might only have five or something or two or something.
When I know when I know one month subscription plan will the supplements be shipped so as not to interrupt daily consumption.
When you have put it a subscription and let's say you do it on the 5th of February and it's on a one month every the 5th of every month. It's going to reduce in our store and it comes up in the store as a subscription. But then we fill it.
So if you want it before that, then you have to time that you have to figure out the timing of that.
So we fill it it automatically populates. So that's what our system does. So it will automatically populate when you how you create that subscription.
Well, if you have some things that you need every 30 days and then you have other things that you need every 45 days, you might want to create multiple subscriptions based upon that.
Well, I need this every 30 days, but I only need this every 60 days. So you'll have to create, you know, maybe you have three things that you need every 60 days, two things you need every 30 days, well, you're going to have two subscriptions then.
You'll need for the world. You need every 30 days will be that or you could have one subscription, but you'll get two models of this and one model of that.
That's something you're going to have to figure out. We don't really have the staff to do that. So please do your math, figure out your benefit.